aujourd'hui c'est vrai que pour le grand
public on se dit c'est quoi passe de la
4g à la fac j'ai c'est un changement si
fonds sera pas forcément compte mais il
faut vraiment l'imaginé comme une
révolution globale mais qui est vraiment
impactante dans notre vie quotidienne
[Musique]
aulas volodia si je prie pour vous
parler d'un sujet très sérieux comme la
5g qu'on va les faire directement au
bord de la plage tout le sujet va pas se
pressent au bord de la plage
ici on est pas mal gré avant de parler
de choses sérieuses comprendre comment
la france va changer votre vie et en
profondeur après on se met mieux
regarder pour 5 secondes
on inspire on prend de l'air iodé
ah ça fait du bien bon séjour à
barcelone hyper sympa hein maintenant il
est l'heure de partir pour quelques
heures en avion retour paris et pour
l'instant on se concentre on va essayer
de comprendre comment la 5g va changer
votre vision profondeur et vous allez
voir franchement si génial
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous sommes à barcelone sur le stand de
qualcomm au mwc partout om 12 cette
année il est écrit la 5g et ici alors
l'a5 jette ici c'est bien beau mais au
final qu'est ce que la 5g qu'est ce
qu'on peut faire avec
qu'est ce qu'elle va nous apporter et
comment elle va réellement changer nos
vies plus de vitesse
loin de latence c'est cool mais qu'est
ce qu'on va faire avec alors mise à part
ce que n'était plus vite télécharger
plus rapidement rallié plus de vidéos ci
et ça ça c'est la partie émergée de
l'iceberg
mais en réalité la seule fille plus que
ça et on n'imagine même pas aujourd'hui
ce qu'on peut faire avec je vous emmène
avec moi on va s'asseoir de qualcomm
on va aller visiter on va faire un tour
essayer de comprendre ce qu'on veut
faire avec la 5g et voit réellement bien
que la fin que je sois là qu'est ce
qu'elle peut nous apporter
[Applaudissements]
alors on commence par la matière la 5g
c'est déjà plus de rapidité plus de
connectivité plus de vitesse
car c'est comme ça qu'ils ont
démocratisé donc la saint jacques ça va
nous permettre d'aller plus vite de
mieux se connecter plus rapidement comme
on sait que sur les usages notamment je
parle de smartphones n'est pas que de
smartphones les usages c'est surtout
beaucoup de multimédia beaucoup de
loisirs beaucoup de connexions réseaux
sociaux soit plus connectés pour être
plus en plus connectés comme de plus en
plus de monde de connecter et même dans
le monde entier en règle générale est
bien pour ça il faut des débits ça
jusque là c'est le constat de base c'est
ça monsieur revel dit bonjour vous êtes
le dire et l'espagne attisant le
directeur france de qualcomm
c'est ça d'accord plein de choses chez
qualcomm on parle beaucoup de sens que
j'ai beaucoup de sujet hyper intéressant
alors là sans que j'y arrive c'est pas
forcément évident de comprendre on peut
faire avec la salle julia est ce que
vous pouvez me donner je dirais une
vision globale de ce que va apporter la
salle g au grand public donc la 5g
effectivement on en parle depuis
plusieurs années c'était beaucoup des
discussions technologique jusqu'à
jusqu'à jusqu'à cette année et cette
année pour la première fois on voit la
5g arrivée dans des produits et on
comprend que la scène j'ai aujourd'hui
se matérialisent et pour des offres
auprès du grand public très
prochainement
et dès 2019 dès l'année 2010 9 sél année
un delà de la 5g pour le grand public ce
qui se fait en france
alors on savait en france d en france
bien sûr il y aura une expérience 5 gt
2019 d'accord que en termes de
performances et évidemment des débits
plus élevés c'est aussi une latence la
plus faible
mais la salle g va pas non seulement
intégrer les
smartphones mais aussi à pénétrer de
nouveaux types de produits sont d'accord
on parle beaucoup évidemment de produits
à est rien pixar façon plus généralement
donc des lunettes
[Musique]
là on se trouve en vous salle où on
parle de réalité virtuelle 132 qualcomm
alors la réalité virtuelle vous
connaissez je vais rien vous apprendre
d'autres cab vous et votre casque
branché à un ordinateur vous gagnez au
monde virtuel
ça c'est la base sauf que là vous êtes
sûr de la réalité virtuelle qui est
franchement différent c'est à dire que
toutes les informations transitent par
l'a5 j'aime votre casque pas se
connecter à la sanguine à un ordinateur
à distance et l'ordinateur distant lui
renvoie l'information et ça peut le
faire ou 4 ko qui complètement ouf
imaginez vous faites de la vermée
branche alors dit ses flûtes ça marche
vous faites exactement la même chose
avec un ordinateur qui peut être à des
milliers de kilomètres et qui vous
renvoie à la formation en temps réel
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais un cas nuage qui est intéressant
c'est à dire que vous avez des lunettes
de réalité augmentée qui se connecte à
la 5g a directement pas du tout
directement les grâce à votre smartphone
en gros vos lunettes se connecte à votre
smartphone ou votre smartphone est
connecté à la 5g et c'est vraiment bien
essayé pour la différence c'est un peu
vous c'est que vous sauviez jusqu'à
voulu faire google avec ses google glace
vous affranchissez d'un modem 5 g dans
vos lunettes qui fait que vous avez un
truc plus petit plus léger et c'est
votre smartphone qui va vous connecter
donc là la réalité augmentée vous l'avez
ça veut donc dire que la sens que j'ai
en fait elle va non seulement apporter
plus de vitesse plus de dix billets - de
latence non plus de ça elle va permettre
à tous nos objets de se connecter
ensemble pour faciliter la vie de
l'utilisateur pour les plus grands en
termes de technologies conçoit pas
failli dans la 4g aurait absolument est
en fait vu les tendances de l'évolution
des usages aujourd'hui dans laquelle j
si les choses continuent à évoluer comme
ça si la 5g n'était pas présente
aujourd'hui
on aurait beaucoup de mal à obtenir le
tenir la route et à tenir les évolutions
qui sont pressentis avec toujours plus
de voitures connectées toujours de
voitures plus autonome toujours des pc
qui sont plus en plus connectés au
cellulaire le volume de données mobiles
double chaque année d'accord et donc on
ait besoin des opérateurs pour gérer ce
volume de blé ont besoin de nouvelles
technologies
il a 5 g va permettre de gérer cet
afflux de demandes de données et en plus
de d2 permettre de développer et de
déployer de nouveaux duels
et en plus de ça ce qu'il faut
comprendre avec la sagesse et elle va se
déployer sur un ensemble sur tous les
objets connectés c'est vraiment leur
évolution majeure pour les outils pour
l'internet fixe pour tous les objets
collectés et au delà de ça même sur la
voiture autonome sur l'automobile parce
que vous le savez la voiture autonome
commencent à arriver
le législateur a pas encore clamé son
boulot mais ça va vraiment finir par
arriver
donc on ne conduira plus on se rassure
notre bagnols elle nous enlève un point
à un point des plus de sécurité alors le
paysage de la conduite ça va devenir un
peu plus délicat à voir comment ça va
évoluer bon là on ne sait pas encore
tout dit en tout cas il faut que ces
voitures qui s'est connecté alors elles
vont se connecter
non seulement directement aux bornes
pour avoir de la 5g où vous aurez des
enfants puissent comme vous conduirai
plus belle qu'on va y avoir du
multimédia on pourra y avoir des infos
vous pourrez communiquer pour avait
bossé dans votre voiture
ça c'est intéressant parce qu'on voit
que même le monde en termes de
l'automobile va changer et donc votre
voiture et va se connecter directement
au bond pour avoir la 5g mais en même
temps elle va communiquer avec tous
autour d'elle elle va communiquer avec
un feu de quelle couleur et le feu je
m'arrête j'avance parce que
effectivement un voiture avec une caméra
quand le voir mais si le feu lui dis
sans même la regarder
non je t'ai rouge n'avancent pas aussi
votre caméra est obstruée qu'elle ne
voit pas en termes de sécurité c'est
franchement autre chose
donc ça c'est cool elle va pouvoir
communiquer avec d'autres voitures
autonomes dédiés attention je suis là
j'ai un exemple les caméras ne voit pas
que la voiture freine et ça c'est quand
même relativement dommage mais si
déclamation frais devant il dit
attention je freine tout le monde
derrière le sait ça vous permet d'avoir
une double sécurité
on imagine plein de cas d'usagé comme ça
et ça c'est franchement il était
intéressant
est-ce que vous pensez que la 5g c'est
vraiment un nouveau monde technologique
qui commence c'est en fait c'est un
élément fondamental qui va changer
qui va changer un certain nombre
d'industries et donc l'importance c'est
d'être là au plus tôt
ouais pour ne pas rater des révolutions
aucune induire aujourd'hui il ya eu le
temps excessivement compressé sur l'a5
gré parce que personne ne veut rater le
tournant de la 5g tout le monde pressent
que la 5g va révolutionner leur propre
industrie sans forcément complètement
identifiée comme ans aujourd'hui mais ce
qui est sûr c'est que personne ne veut
rater le tournoi mais quand on parle de
5 g en france on parle forcément 2
orange orange qui déploie la 5g alors
c'est assez énorme et derrière déjà
j'étais passé voir sur leur stand et on
avait déjà parlé de 5g déploiement qui
est intéressant parce qu'effectivement
autant on va compter technologique avec
qualcomm qui met en place les modèles
qui va passer pas mal de solutions et il
ya le côté opérateurs parce que c'est
bien que l'on dise que la 5g et là il
faut qu'à ceux déployés alors je n'ai
aucun doute sur le fait que orange et
les autres opérateurs la des plus
rapidement du moins dans les grandes
métropoles pour les plus petites villes
les villages ça va être un peu plus
compliqué ça prendra plus de temps ça va
arriver
c'était là une question à laquelle j ai
quelques années ça va arriver et là
effectivement on a toutes les
problématiques de 5g côté opérateurs et
ça aussi san.fr ats alors on en
reparlera probablement du côté
opérateurs ça nécessiterait aussi
vidéo dédiée il ya beaucoup c'est à dire
dessus vocation c'est vraiment cool
alors de quelle manière un travail
qualcomm justement pour apporter ces
solutions 5g innovante vous fabrique
effectivement du matériel du cac manière
à ce que nous prépare la salle g de
quelle manière on prépare l'avenir de la
peau des technologiques
ça marche donc ça fait une petite
dizaine d'années qu'on travaille sur la
singer j'imagine donc s'effacer pas
sorti du jour au lendemain
aujourd'hui on est dans une phase dite
d'industrialisation à tous les sujets
technologiques se dire derrière nous
pour la génération actuelle est
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui en phase de
commercialisation
donc aujourd'hui on est face à des à
décharge industrielle il faut avoir le
volume de composants nécessaires il faut
équiper un certain nombre de nos clients
aujourd'hui on a annoncé 12
une quinzaine de clients fait qu'ils ont
qui travaille sur une solution mais
c'est plus d'une trentaine de device
trentaine de solide de produits qui sont
en cours de développement qui vont tous
à être disponible courant mai 2019 on
travaille aussi avec tous les opérateurs
du monde sur tous les continents et donc
c'est un travail énorme de
d'industrialisation pour on va dire et
pour avoir les chaînes qui en fait
lorsque le truc qu'il faut l'imaginer
avec la 5g c'est que elle va pas
remplacer la fibre ou forcément laquelle
j'ai tout de suite
elle va venir la compléter elle doit
venir apporter une solution alternative
la cinquième à travailler de concert
avec la 4g comme on a aujourd'hui sur
laquelle josé pas la qualité ou la vie
la 3g vous avez dû s vous avez carrément
pas de bol ça sera un peu la même chose
4g 5 g 3g lorsque vous rentrez chez vous
il va se connecter à votre wifi et
pourquoi pas on paye à gérer et se dire
que bat alors que la connexion wi fi des
plus beaux nous ça marche pas la 5g
prend volée alors pourquoi pas avec un
top 5 g pour l'ensemble de la mairie
[Musique]
ça que j'ai est également sur le stand
htc avec un outil pub 5 g alors qui vous
servira à quoi seules grosses
intéressante seul il va se connecter à
la 5g et en wifi vous allez pouvoir
connecter vos différents device à la
maison alors la question qu'on peut se
poser c'est à terme
est-ce que la 5g pour y remplacer votre
connexion fibre ou agresser l'adversaire
en place et pourquoi pas une collègue
son fils c'est un sujet qui est très
intéressant
hu a priori rien ne change et à une
conférence call comme élise et non on ne
pense pas que la salle g va remplacer la
fiv en quelque sorte seule on remplace
un modem et par connecter votre maison
directement la 500 d'où est venu le
leader comme aujourd'hui samedi un livre
pour l'infection se projeter pour
l'entreprise comme qualcomm jean
bourassa mais aujourd'hui la cij et dans
10 ans 10 ans 15 ans comment est ce
qu'on arrive à prédire sa 10 ans l'agent
de dix ans en arrière 2009 comme en 2009
on se dit la 5g va arriver ça y est il
est temps de se préparer on sent des
usages arrivé aux 100 des besoins sont
des évolutions technologiques
on sent une évolution de la société qui
est une évolution toujours vers plus de
digitalisation et dans un monde toujours
plus mobiles et est donc on se doute
bien que les besoins de connectivité
sans fil que vont pas cesser de le
passer c'est d'être d'être d'être
demandée avant donc très très fort pour
ce pur pour adresser ce besoin
après c'est du travail de recherche
quelles sont les meilleures technologies
qu'on peut
pensez au cas où on peut penser pour on
va dire répondre aux besoins naturels
de l'évolution
[Musique]
la 5g et la ouais mais ce qu'on peut en
faire réellement derrière n'existe pas
encore en espagne de feuilles blanches
qui va être écrit par les opérateurs par
effectivement des sociétés comme
qualcomm mais également par un
écosystème global d'entreprises qui vont
trouver des solutions innovantes tout
cas ce qui est bien est ce qu'on va
c'est qu'à 5 g ça ouvre de nouveaux
horizons
un nouveau monde et quand on nous dit la
sagesse est une révolution c'est pas
deux minots c'est une réalité et je
crois que ça sera encore plus dans les
arrières bien ça on en parle ensemble ça
fait 30 ans que volcom existe avec ce
cycle ce cercle vertueux dire de
recherche développement innovation
commercialisation d'industrialisation
c'est un cercle d'innovation comme ça
qu'ils qui a permis depuis 30 ans deux
de partir nous on était simple téléphone
qui faisait de la voie jusqu'à d'aidé
mis aujourd'hui où on voit dans son
téléphone des débits qui peuvent aller
jusqu'à 5 5 gigabits sa saveur
tout ça en l'espace d'une vingtaine
d'années alors la question c'est ça
c'est qu'au final vous avez une
expertise technologique et au final
cette expertise technologique reprises
par des entreprises vont permet changer
les sociétés d'une certaine manière
influer sur l'évolution des sociétés et
on avait justement cette discussion avec
monsieur marin dix ans en france et
ailleurs c'est vraiment intéressant de
se dire on n'arrive pas aujourd'hui à
appréhender ce que la 5g va réellement
apporté très clairement avec une techno
comme ça qu'il va se passer des choses
c'est clair c'est évident aujourd'hui on
sait pas mais on prend un exemple par
exemple le fait d'avoir la 4g la 4g ça
permet une boîte comme hubert d'exister
c'est les pommes c'est joli et des
semenciers pas la cacher
hubert aujourd'hui n'existerait pas donc
cette révolution
dubé risation n'existerait pas donc les
choses vont se passer un petit peu de la
même manière avec la 5g pas un nouvel
humeur mais pourquoi pas dans l'idée de
nouveaux usages des choses plus
intéressantes plus parfaite alors
l'autre qui fait un petit peu flippant
c'est de se dire que comme on paye tout
le temps connecté partout avec beaucoup
de vitesse
on peut se dire que les gens vont
s'enfermer temps de la réalité virtuelle
dans le lard ait augmenté
c'est pas impossible mais néanmoins il
ya un vrai brute d'éducation derrière il
ya un vrai boulot de transformation
d'entreprise même des médias leurs
responsabilités pour présenter et
expliquer et ça c'est intéressant
il ya des choses qui vont se mettre en
place ce qui attire vraiment ma
curiosité c'est de se dire mais à quoi
va ressembler le monde dans dix ans dans
20 ans grâce à la salle g aujourd'hui
c'est vrai que pour le grand public on
se dit c'est quoi parce que la 4g à la
fin que j'ai c'est un changement aussi
fonds sera pas forcément compte mais il
faut vraiment imaginé comme une
révolution globale mais qui est vraiment
impactante dans notre vie quotidienne
qu'est ce que vous pensez de l'idée de
la 5g est ce que pour vous c'est une
bonne nouvelle est ce que pour vous
c'est une fausse bonne nouvelle est ce
que pour vous c'est une vraie bande
annonce est ce que c'est une fausse
bonne annonçait ce qui au final la 5g
pas vraiment apporter quelque chose ou
alors est ce que c'est juste un peu plus
de rapidité est ce que vous imaginez le
monde de demain en 5 j qu'est ce que
vous imaginez qu est ce que vous
aimeriez ça c'est hyper à des nations
aussi de se projeter un peu dans le
futur qu est ce que vous vous
imagineriez comme kde usage qu est ce
que vous souhaiteriez et comment est ce
que vous voyez ce monde avec le monde
encore plus connectés ça vous fait
flipper savourant un patient science est
ce que ça vous tente
et c'est vraiment ça que ce soit
intéressant cédé 6 2 2
comprendre ce qui va se passer
aujourd'hui on voit la 5g marie la 5 gt
si c'est écrit dans l'ensemble on ne
peut pas le louper au mwc
il est écrit partout la 5g il a donc
pourquoi la 5g là elle arrive mais ce
qui est intéressant c'est pas tout de
suite c'est un peu plus tard dites moi
vous ce que vous en pensez
comment vous voyez les choses et escaut
finale 7 5 g ça vous tente vous laisse
médias tout ça en bas en commentaire et
croyez moi la 5g on va reparler pas la
techno pour la techno mais vraiment les
usages un nouveau monde qui s'ouvre on
est un petit peu un lob de nouvelles
révolutions qu'on imagine pas mais il ya
une vraie accélération technologique et
le fait d'avoir des collections toujours
plus puissants toujours plus rapide saad
a encore amplifié le phénomène
il n'ya même pas 10 ans il ya dix ans
les smartphones arriver aujourd'hui le
smartphone si on a la pression que ça a
toujours existé
c'est juste ouais ok hallucinant il se
passe beaucoup de choses ça va continuer
et moi j'adore ça donc on va en parler
ensemble vous invite à vous abonner
poursuivre cette révolution
on va la vivre ensemble tout en masquant
a fait bientôt yahoo